[Music]
when your team is down
when the clock is ticking when the
pressure is on and you're the only one
left these are the moments that really
separate the greats
from the goats here he comes once again
the first base is a trend he's going to
hit the ground there is cold oh
wow that's jumping what is it going on
right now
how does he do this clutches are so
incredible because
they're the perfect storm they happen
when a player is down and has
incredible skill a little bit of luck
and the courage to do the impossible
and today we wanted to celebrate the
players with the balls of steel
to clutch it out but just before we get
into all of this i want to make sure
that you are subscribed to the channel
if you haven't done so already we are
still on the road to 2 million subs
and you can help us get there and with
that out the way let's get into the top
10 clutches plays
in esports history
starting off today's list is the newest
addition to the clutch hall of fame
kadian's incredible 1v4 play at the esl
pro
league season 13 finals the leader
calling well above his years clearing
the night
you're an animal heroic have done it and
i just can't believe it 40
of their team only together since
february heroic was on the verge of
victory but gambit put up a fight
heroic just needed one round to close
out the map and win the grand finals
but with only kadyan left in a 1v4
situation on mirage a site
things looked impossible and that's when
cadian
clutched it out and made history with
nothing but a pistol
and nerves of steel oh yeah ah yeah oh
oh my god he's knifed him and he's
gotten away with your punch time to get
nervous
there's no way there's no way katie you
can't win pro league like this
you can't win pro league like this no
way
exiles left 40 seconds and the bombs on
a take your time son you're about to
make the play of your career
the leader calling well above his years
clearing corners
you're an animal heroic have done it and
i just can't believe it 40
of their team only together since
february
and with nothing but a p250 chad i'm in
disbelief
[Music]
coming in at number nine is arguably the
most clutch
play in siege history
ness was in a 1v5 situation at the latin
america pro league
season 1 semi-finals pain gaming took
out the rest of his black dragon's
teammates in a matter of
seconds but ness was still alive and
that meant
he could clutch it out
[Music]
meant that black dragons went to the
grand finals which they won
in a 3-0 sweep if that's not clutch
what is taking number eight on our list
is the clutches cs go play to
ever win a major stewie's on his own but
look at the time
look at the time there's seven seconds
they're trying to build pyramids but
there's no more play
stewie's wondering around we're going to
overtime cloud9 was down
14-15 against faze clan at the boston
major grand
finals cloud9 had to win this round to
force overtime otherwise
faze would win the map and the major
faze sent
three players to b while most of c9 was
off at
a that meant stewie2k was all on his own
in a 1v3 situation and with just eight
seconds on the clock
things looked impossible for stewie but
stewie had other plans he's gotta go
back
stewie's on his own but look at the
climb look at the time there's seven
seconds i've got a bomb
they're trying to build pyramids but
there's no more play
stewie's walking around we're going to
overtime
darkness
[Applause]
stewie's incredible play pushed the
series into overtime where cloud9
won it all and became the first north
american team
to ever win a cs go major
moving on now and number seven entry is
a play
so clutch it was worth 11 million
dollars
gets the goal in the grand finals of tia
og was on the back foot against psg
lgd lgd was up two to one
and were looking to close out the game
so they jumped og
and it looked like they won the team
fight with only ana and seb
left has he got it army getting stood up
by the concept but he's able to wait for
him after i've got thompson
blinks in he gets to hang out with f5
with a snowball save
anna was completely outnumbered and it
looked like seb was out of the fight
but then out of nowhere he came
in clutch they get thompson thompson
can he do it here at our bell
he gets the goal of his
lifetime og won that game and the series
taking home millions in prize money and
of course
started a legacy that saw them win ti
again
the very next year
taking the number six spot on our list
is a buzzer beat to play that will
make your heart stop
[Applause]
nrg was up against team dignitas in the
rlcs season 5 grand
finals and dignitas were ahead 3-2
all they had to do was prevent nrg from
scoring a goal for the remaining
4 seconds and they'd be world champions
but in rocket league the game goes on so
long as the ball
doesn't touch the ground as the clock
hits zero
nrg kept the ball alive and even pushed
towards diggs net
but for a second it didn't look like
they could score a goal
then out of nowhere justin
energy need this immediately they've got
the kickoff in their favor
caleb tries to clear it is almost every
just has to hit the floor
by the panda puts it the long way and
it's almost there
justin keeps it alive teleports up there
[Applause]
it was an amazing play and although
nrg ended up losing the series justin's
incredible
zero second goal created rocket league's
most
memorable and iconic moment
marking the halfway spot on our list is
eqo absolutely
dominating paris eternal at the 2020
overwatch league summer showdown finals
and now it is overtime actually moving
over to the tracer to try and deny but
eq oh
eqo what a player what a star
with a payload just inches away from the
checkpoint
fusion was struggling to get it through
the gate as the clock ran out and
over time began it seemed like eternal
had fusion
stopped in their tracks that was until
eqo stepped up with
genji and clutched out the checkpoint
with a combination of
incredible mechanics and pixel perfect
timing
to hop to and from the payload while
keeping overtime
alive everyone is weak equal with the
blade
pulls it through builds it up will it be
enough one kill to
kill are you kidding me eqo now finds it
with the third
and now it is over time actually moving
over to the tracer to try and deny but
eq oh
eq what a player what a star
unbelievable performance in the overtime
clutch and normally it's carpe
normally he steps up but this time eqo
reminds everybody at home why he's still
on this roster
coming in at number four is a miraculous
melee clutch
not giving him anything nobody gets
anything he gets that
that could be it but hey
[Applause]
read the double jump waits out the air
dodge and romano
he's gonna play one more set it was the
2016
evo smash melee grand finals between
hungrybox and armada
and it looked like armada was about to
win it all armada was up
two stalks and on match point while
hungrybox's jigglypuff was
barely hanging in there and a single
clean hit
would end the set and the tournament
oh yeah all right now 2016 is on the
line right now
one more big hit from armada is going to
end this tournament still
hungrybox remained calm he kept fox
at a distance ducking dodging and
waiting until
just the right moment and then he did
the
impossible
punishment yeah way too hard to get
anything up though but that back here is
probably close up the start
probably easy stuff right is he going to
reset the bracket or zomata just going
to close it out right here let's go
armada is not giving him anything
he gets that could be it
to reset the bracket the reason reads
the double jump waits out the air dodge
romano
he's gonna play one more set hungrybox
sitting back down
hungrybox forced a bracket reset and won
3-2 in the second set earning his first
and only evo world championship
there's a reason they call him clutch
box
taking the number three spot is csgo's
most iconic clutch
heco's last stand he gets the fourth
he's odd for the acer he gets it
with all of his team liquid teammates
dead pico was alone against
all five members of sponsorless they
could kill him or defuse the bomb but
either way they were about to take the
map to top it all off
hiko didn't even have a good gun he was
stuck with a tech nine
but of course you can never count out
the clutch god himself
trickling four spots less on that ct
side it will once again just be
hiko is he about to pull off the alamo
he's got three from behind quad can he
find a fourth
he gets the fourth he's on for the
eighth and he gets
it
did that just happen
our runner-up play is league of legends
most famous clutch
praise ash arrow look at the air
teleport he's stopped
which means they can put it away they're
trying to bring it down
this is not going
now besides the fact that it's like the
moba version of a no scope
this play is so clutch because of just
how perfectly it went down
it was game two of the semi-final
matchup between rox tigers and
skt gaming out worlds 2016 and rox was
looking to close it out
praying kuro went deep into skt's base
to end the game
but skt started backing to try and stop
them and that's when prey
fired a blind arrow into the bot lane
and they even got the pick off on bang
rox doesn't actually have to stop
pushing right now they can delay the
recalls down
look at this
stopped duke from backing and basically
secured rocks the win
as the remaining skt members were just
too staggered to fight them off
but steph's running low
[Applause]
[Applause]
ended up losing the best of five to skt
but praise incredible play still remains
the most clutch league moment of
all time of course there's only one play
clutch enough to take our number one
entry the digo parry or evo moment 37.
in the losers final of evo 2004 street
fighter 3
third strike tournament justin wong had
daigo umahara
on the ropes justin had a comfortable
lively and a super ready to go
while daigo was playing with a sliver of
health
even if he blocked justin's next attack
it was over for him
he'd have to parry any attack justin
decided to seal the deal with a super
figuring there was no way diego had the
skill to perfectly parry 15 hits with
frame perfect timing but justin was
wrong
this is the most iconic play in esports
history
sure but it's also one of the most
clutch
if daigo missed a single parry if he
messed up his
punish combo if he made any decision
other than the exact
ones he made with all the pressure in
the world on him
he would have lost but he didn't and the
play
is history
and that as they say is that which one
of those
was your favorite and more importantly
did we miss out any good ones i know
there are
far more than 10 good clutch players out
there so let us know we did
in the meantime thanks for watching and
i'll see you all in the next one oh
it's all case a timing night the player
sees each other
oh my god guys please guys